the orille might be on life support but
Seth McFarland speaks there's no
official death certificate yet so does
the over live welcome to St TR TV and M
channel so SE McFarlin very recently did
an interview for the rap and he was
asked about the Orville and this is what
he said all I can tell you is that there
is no official death certificate for the
Orville theen told the rapping an
interview and asked about an update for
the Possible season 4 it's still with us
I can't go any further than that at the
moment there are too many
factors Scott Grimes who added to this
because um I think this was an interview
actually about Ted the TV show that's
coming out with Scott Grimes also stars
in I don't know why we're still talking
about it it's not dead in any sort of
way whatsoever it's just about when
where and how and building the stuff
again Grimes told the rap I'm excited
about it because it's one of the
greatest things to work on so I just
have my fingers crossed and I know Seth
wants to do it and that usually holds a
lot of power and I hope he gets it done
because it's one of his babies and he
just loves it and it's a blast to work
on so we'll quickly break down what
Scott said he is basically saying it's
coming back that it's happening and that
he is very very
confident but obviously he's the actor
he doesn't actually have any power or
control in this matter Seth doesn't seem
to be quite as confident so if you are a
regular Sid trer you'll know that I've
been talking about the Orville quite a
bit and there has been a little bit of a
roller coaster I dropped um a few months
ago now that Hulu actually were having
second thoughts about moving forwards
with the Orville now I never said at the
time it was cancelled but what I did say
was Executives over at Hulu was saying
uh we don't want it um it can go
somewhere else now Seth McFarland's
company fuzzy bear Productions does
control the rights to the Orville and in
theory he could take the show to another
network but I also then told you
exclusively and just after that that
actually there were people at Disney
Executives that actually did want the
Orville to continue and very keen for it
to continue they were the people
involved with it when it was at Fox and
they're the people that were involved it
when it moved over to the Hulu now this
is a little bit complicated because even
during the strikes there were
conversations about the Orville and its
fourth season but they were very keen to
bring the budget down the third season
New Horizons did have a significant Step
Up in budget they were hoping to really
take a lot of sethc farin's momentum and
popularity and build a franchise now New
Horizons did well but it didn't do quite
as well as well Executives were hoping
or maybe quite as well as the budget
suggested it needed to there is also the
issue though that all the streaming
platforms have spent way too much money
in the last few years and they want the
budgets to come down anyway so they were
talking about a much smaller budget for
season 4 I actually don't think that's a
bad thing I think the first two seasons
were the best thing about the Orville I
want more of that humor to come back and
I actually didn't mind some of the
cheesy special effects I kind of felt it
fit the show to be honest because we
don't really need another Star Trek
style show we want the orille and the
orille is a little bit different on
purpose so maybe the very polished
expensive special effects weren't as
needed but let's break down what Seth
actually said because I do think he
makes one point it's still with us I
can't go further than that at the moment
there are too many factors what factors
is he talking about well again if you're
a regular side tracker you'll know that
because of this thing I was talking
about Hulu saying that maybe we don't
want to do this anymore but Disney
saying they do well Hulu isn't
completely controlled by Disney yet but
it will be soon there is an agreement
for Disney to completely buy out the
rest of the shares of Hulu um the other
50% I think it's for about $8 billion
doar it's a lot of money um and that is
supposed to be going through pretty much
this year so when that deal goes through
Disney will have full control of Hulu
and if those Executives that want the
Orville do insist it will happen and it
will happen with Hulu there are other
factors though Seth McFarland is
incredibly busy and in the past very
least he's wanted to really control
everything about the orille he writes it
he stars in it obviously he really has
been very protective of it even Scott
Grim said there it's his baby now I've
been told that actually executives Hulu
the main reason why they were a little
less Keen to move forward with this was
because they couldn't see how they were
going to get a regular series out of it
they want something annually they want a
series every year with Seth McFarland
writing it starring it and everything
else they couldn't see how that was
possible considering all of the other
projects he's got going on at the moment
he's doing a lot of stuff with peacock
at the moment there's obviously the Ted
series he's done scripts for a couple of
movies and actually he's got another big
project with them coming up and some
sort of like uh superhero Academy thing
and a comic book based story that he
wants to do so they were saying look we
can't keep doing this we can't keep
doing a series every two or three years
we need it every year and if Seth
McFarland is insisting that he's going
to control every aspect of the show how
do we move forwards with it now I do
wonder whether this might have actually
just been a negotiation tactic a sort of
yeah okay we're not going to do it
anymore but really they were just hoping
that Seth would come back with a counter
offer and you know if they say said look
this is our problem and if we can't fix
it we're not moving forwards and then
Seth comes back and explains how he's
going to fix it I'm being told actually
the Hope was that Seth would agree to
bring in other writers that his
character would maybe step back a little
bit and maybe Grayson would step
forwards as the new captain and that
captain merer or maybe Admiral Mercer by
that point would come in and out of the
show when Seth mcf fallin's time table
allowed him but other actors would step
up and they would take the lead if
you're enjoying the video don't forget
to like subscribe and hit that Bell
notification so you miss none of our new
videos and most importantly leave a
comment it's a community after all we
want to know what you think
too now I don't know where we're at with
that at the moment but Seth McFarland's
comments does seem to suggest that these
are the type of conversations that are
going on and even Scott Grim says it's
not about when or if it's about how and
that's the problem that's always been
the problem with the Orville if Seth
mcaren insists on protecting his baby
and doing everything for it we're not
going to get a season every year but the
executives over at Hulu insist upon it
Seth mcfallen only has so many hours in
the day and if he wants to do other
projects it's going to be very difficult
now it is fair to say SE Fallin is a bit
of a
workaholic but there are as I say only
so many hours in the day there is it's
physically impossible for him to do
everything and it's not just about the
fact that he's the writer for a lot of
these projects He also then does put his
voice to them which means he then does
have to do interviews when something new
comes out he has to do these press
junkets he has to go all over the world
and do chat shows and things to promote
programs like Ted these shows cost a lot
lot of money to produce so the actors
and the star and the writer and the
director do have to do these things it's
impossible for Seth to do that and then
write a series and produce and Then star
in a series like the oral as well so
where are we at right now in a nutshell
Hulu right now could take it or leave it
they really do feel that if the orille
came back which they would love it to
come back it needs to be a reg annual
series and they can't see how that's
possible Seth McFarland desperately
wants to do it and a lot of the actors
want to do it maybe not Adrien picki who
obviously was in an interview recently
basically saying she did three maybe
that's all she did but her beef with it
was that it's just economically not
worth doing if you're only going to do a
series every like three years if they
pay her I absolutely certain she would
very happily come back Disney though
aring to do this and if they can get
Seth mcfallen on board to do any project
they really want him they know that he
is a massive Talent they love everything
he's ever done on Fox and they want to
keep him working with them his other
projects over at NBC and peacock they
don't really like that particularly and
they want to keep him to themselves as
much as possible if he wants the Orville
they will give it him and that is where
we're at right now this is still very
possible to return but it is very very
complicated so the show might not be
dead it's definitely not officially
cancelled but it's on life support there
is so many factors involved in this now
that it's going to be very difficult for
it to return and it's only going to
return if fuzzy bear Productions and
Seth McFarland can guarantee a regular
series of the show if they can't I don't
think it'll return
finally I have to say to I did a
prediction video at the start of the
year and I asked 15 um industry insiders
whether they felt the Orville would
return or not 11 said no four said they
were pretty confident it would so people
that actually work in the industry at
you know agents etc etc they don't think
it's going to happen and these are the
people that actually work in the
industry as I say and my prediction was
that I don't think it will but that is
only my opinion I'm hoping that if Seth
mcfar wants this enough and he's willing
to compromise we will get more of the
orill but guys what do you think get
into the comments and tell me this is a
show that I would love to see return but
it's going to be different without Seth
mcfallen at the helm without him writing
all of the episodes maybe just
overseeing script without him starring
would it be a completely different
proposition could it actually be better
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com sidre where most of our
videos Premiere first and you get to see
them without the adverts finally go to
c.co do.uk which is our dedicated
website and we do stories based on a lot
of our videos go check it out as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time now if you are a regular sidet
tracker you'll know that I've been
talking about the a little bit and it's
leester
say leter
[Music]
say